- [Instructor] Let's say that
I have a random variable X
which is equal to the number
of dogs that I see in a day.
And random variable Y is
equal to the number of cats
that I see in a day.
Let's say I also know what
the mean of each of these
random variables are, the expected value.
So the expected value of X
which I could also denote
as the mean of our random
variable X let's say I expect
to see three dogs a day
and similarly for the cats,
the expected value of Y is
equal to I could also denote
that as the mean of Y is going
to be equal to and this is
just for the sake of (mumbles)
let's say I expect to see
four cats a day.
And pretty much we define how
you take the mean of a random
variable or the expected
value for a random variable.
What we're going to think
about now is what would be
the expected value of X plus
Y or other way of saying
that the mean of the sum of
these two random variables.
Well it turns out, and I'm
not proving it just yet,
that the mean of the sum of
random variables is equal to
the sum of the means.
So this is going to be equal
to the mean of random variable
X plus the mean of random variable Y.
And so in this particular case,
if I were to say well what's
the expected number of dogs
and cats that I would see
in a given day.
Well I would add these two
means, it would be three plus
four it would be equal to seven,
so in this particular case
it is equal to three plus
four which is equal to seven.
And similarly if I were to ask
you the difference if I were
to say how many more cats in
a given day would I expect
to see than dogs, so the
expected value of Y minus X.
What would that be?
Well intuitively you might
say well hey if we can add
random...
If the expected value of the
sum is the sum of the expected
values, then the expected
value or the mean of
the difference will be the
differences of the means
and that is absolutely true.
So this is the same thing as
the mean of Y minus X which is
equal to the mean of Y is going
to be equal to the mean of Y
minus the mean of X, minus the mean of X.
And in this particular case,
it would be equal to four
minus three, minus three is equal to one.
So another way of thinking about
this intuitively is I would
expect to see on a given
day one more cat than dog.
The example that I just
used this is discrete random
variables, on a given day I
wouldn't see 2.2 dogs or pi
dogs, the expected value itself
does not have to be a whole
number 'cause you could of
course average it over many days.
But this same idea that the
mean of a sum is the same thing
as a sum of means and the
mean of a difference of random
variables is the same as
the difference of the means.
In a future video I'll do a proof of this.